ξ και ό κάπινο μετά πάως το ανότα των δικαστήριο και αθόνουμε πανηγύρικά κάθουνταν οκτώδικαστές
το αν δαστο ένον της ελλάδος και όχι μόνο με αθώσε μουεζήατους διάταξε να μου
επιστρέψουν πίσω κατά της ιγ και όπου για με ξεκαινα έα νάλομε μεγάλον καιφαάλε που
φαίνεται που τιπροβλήματα ντημετωπίζι η λενική δικαι ωςήν νυπαμέ όμω να αφήκουμετα της γοσύνης να
μάι έρκεσαι στην κύπρον μάριση αναλαμβάνει στων εμπιαγό λευκωσίας δηλώσεις τότε που άφησαν εποχή κριβώς
έκανε τον υπιαγόλευκωσίας ανέβηκε σημαντικά αλλά παντελάλες ότι ήταν συισαβωικάτο βίτσοαδιάκάσου να παίνεςμε στο γπεδο
καισε βρίζουν θαντάτο δυναδή να ένανάνθρωπο κουμα εξωμανή καπνιστήν υπέρβαρο να άρκισον γιατί μουν και
νρκε τοήθελασυμασία φεραονάρκι ως θέλει α τοχειρο προτούν νων πισκακιούν να το αναγνωρίζουν και ήθελα
εγουν να πολύ στασ καη λικράι θελ πώ το αποέλο αλλά πρήκαν πόδιά που κάποιο
ανόματα γνοστάτότε της τότε οποχής α μεθαελάνα δεν τρποτο γιατί και όοεολογιστής μου τοότε ο
αντόνιος ασσότης ήταν με στον λεμμο και πά πήραμε μεσ το λιπιακό τον πρώτο χρόνον
κατάφερα και πήρ πιραμε ευρώπη δρμαδεήσαμε δεύτερει χασά το πρωτά θλεμα τότε μάστε για να
βαθμό που την ομόνια και όέχασατοπου το αποέλ μορις πρετα πέλ αλλά γιατί το αματον
το πράμα για ανακανοπίσω των αρκήσεις μόσμο διτον που σας είπαπι πός δουλεύκιον κέφαλος ευκαλένταραγια
ός δαθαμέ και τός δαθαμέτρεντ επλέρωννα για να που πισκαγίουμε στο γύπεδο κίνααδήλωσησστη ισέια να
αγοράσου και το γρασίδηνα καλά τούτον τα πελάρες καλέτύτον ήταν τάξακεπουμε ένα θα κοσι κανένα
ποτεψεμα πότ ίμαι θέ